[Music]
hey guys today we are going to be having
a really fun Spanish challenge so I'm
going to be challenging Casey he's right
here hola oh you were I'm gonna be
challenging him in a way where we're
going to be building you see those boxes
right there we're gonna be building a
dresser and I'm going to be giving
directions to Casey in espanol because
Casey has recently been learning Spanish
through babble so thank you babble for
sponsoring this video
babble is the number one language
learning app in the world did you guys
know that I don't know that the reason
why babbles number one is because the
languages that you're learning they
teach you in a way where you will be
using the language in real-life
scenarios the very first lesson on
babble is learning how to say no
entiendo and vagina which means I don't
understand and aprender español means
learning Spanish and boy that's a wrap
which means please repeat a movie inin
that is like I'm like oh my god those
are like the go-to things you would want
to know like you see that like - really
because you've been learning you can't
even have the year ago times kind of
make sense a bit right but it's so I'm
like absolutely applicable I love it as
you guys know we have been talking about
this on our channel for so long the fact
that I have been wanting to brush up on
my Spanish and he has been wanting to
learn Spanish what because I want to
communicate with your side of the family
I want to communicate to you and I want
to be able to like know enough Spanish
where like our children and hopefully
Isaac - picks up on wanting to learn
Spanish
you want to pass on that water filter is
important it's just so sick to like know
another language in like okay you should
do not speak space because of that
reason we are so excited to partner with
Babel and we're also so excited to let
you know that if you click on the
description down below you will see a
link and that link will give you 50% off
Babel can you believe that like that's a
huge discount but it's only available
for a limited time guys so if you're
trying to jump on this amazing deal jump
on it right now because I honestly don't
know how long this deal is gonna be
available so make sure to check out
babble so what are you currently working
on in the app okay so right now I'm at
I'm doing the chapter review I've
finished the chapter right now it says
what does kinetise mean and I'm like I
know what that means
who are you hey that shine it's me feel
so good
yeah these Padres sewn profesor Dez if
any because I've learned from this app
that Padre means father but when it at
an S at the end in plural form Padres
means parents muy bien
so because of that I know this one means
my parents are teachers muy bien
do you know how much time you've spent
on the app so far think I spent a total
of about two hours they've only done the
first chapter I recently found this out
but did you know fifteen hours of babble
time equates to an entire College
semester of Spanish like there've
actually had studies based on this and
that's what they found out we're all
night 15 hours on an app that's way
easier than actually going into a
classroom because I tried going into a
classroom to learn Mandarin that was
really difficult so it's like at your
fingertips super easy so like I said one
more time check out the link in the
description or 50% off Babel and
find your mind learn a new language
watch next time you meet vlog Ruby
polygons
I remember seeing on the app that they
have like Dutch French Portuguese
Norwegian I'm actually starting the
French version of the app because it's a
latin-based language so I'm like you
know I know a little bit just a tiny
little bit when Joe pants were messy to
actually learn an entire like sentence
and all that stuff so we can actually
have conversations but today though
we're gonna be focusing on Espanola a
linghu academia glass that II was a
practical look at fastest look at the
Evanson yellow and babble you've almost
saw it look at service kiseki Arriba por
que es them wave live I enjoy stroke
Otto it was not carry more severe thorn
wavelets arrived analysis scelera and
contest a key from the llama second
through it
no sense of la palabra perfecto para
esto porque yo tambien estoy tratando de
hablar milling y es de mettre bow mucho
okay concerns paciencia score me go away
pero para empezar Louella instrucciones
Conoco 3 esta pista merlin e initiative
a surreal blast kappa
see how do you say open it do you man
do the middle of homicides per average
velocity say open in espanol the color
will see where no Manchus see the car
that's it come on sale every guess I
breathe I breathe gets every J KS yeah
Bria's vs. every year ha ha exactamente
exactamente good and we am given the
nice day
pero como si si si and Obion in Espanola
get the study end of en como se va -
yeah porchetta Bramante como esta en toi
tu EST bien pero la history English dr.
Sandoz there I said Kitano digas en
espanol gnosis english or espanol no mas
rapido despacio despacio motherland oh
yeah despacio but the Pilar be and
rapido por que lo go Norman Chemnitz ok
the 6lr of but I meet Sammy muy muy
facil we passed it for fasting passage
Oh si si si si vaminos will is in
parameter man this ambience necesito que
usar miss Allegro mucho Snowmass
parabola Dennis
it is a widening HDC of fairness others
bracket to oppressor nosotros and all
gladness yo may assume they are not
revealing what your thought is okay it
says we pray meddling what Cassie
Masurian saris yo primero up and the
habla espanol after say in English II
which is against the Sunnah wanna
practice a router que sigue well I had
qual nobody's the primero for Esther you
know el primero era direcciones babysit
thing is like a primero de uno muy bien
muy bien
no no okay yes it gets it Wow
no no no no please read no puedes ver
las instrucciones porque los voy a dar
mikito mucho shut your head
okay no Louis okay primero Mississippi
ah yes
it's the noise oh yeah whoa no it's the
noise no it's no it's they're not know s
nose no nose no no no more below get
that law says oh yes okay fellow I Betsy
will pay us a caca
put Kapena mustard mustard Adam I see
Louie maybe a and a cement the mister
okay we're okay muy way sir Marilla no
more bear sauce add on this parent on to
some interest alright well college is
the PS a-- no I said no it's just no
non-autonomous a broken four semesters a
very old Ella right but they I said the
barman Volterra
Othello Volta hello I see what yeah
AHA muy bien and we be okay
Samira our on Donder Stan lost or Neos
donde esta where is lost or Neos store
Neos the screws aha maybe is the nail in
the box and ricotta in another box
little quad I do look at the seat it's
the end it's the same style as the
mastic see see fellas he must've known
the toilet see donde donde don't fill up
the math there are we how we of si si
toilet no no no no okay we're okay
en práctica panino padrino's son
perceive us
it was Purdue's loss tornadoes
Piero's lost money or ne-yo's repeating
das Neos no los dos vinhos lost or Neos
estan perdidos esta videos well videos
and ethos we end understand quest
repeaters screws told me yours don't
kneel screws
patitos Los perdidos uh-huh missing
better videos those who you ain't got no
again I understand yet more chorus all
see well is this because like I know
we're all awesome number of us on this
fella i'ma just catches a key suspect el
número de vino' even owe me rollers use
numero dos
no si s numero uno al otro donde esta el
numero dos para sa kappa like kappa hey
lost omnia closer in contrast a basura
no aqui na mila at least Atala avert it
estoy bien no Horita necesitamos lost or
mios los novios que necesitamos sone
fearful oh I see
so most people oh hey boy listen fast
echo or melt oh wow Methos ah no I says
no no
a super set off necesitas ah Tao it was
lost and Miranda loss it follows
mathematics a handless most grandiose
I have maybe an SOC SoC necesitas Quatro
Quatro de esos Quatro yes ellos hasta
poner aware Volta a look with the eyes
though necesitas encontrar la fiesta
I still grande grande Grande High so
snow again minami-osawa color to los
cuatro tornado mm-hmm no pero Mira
necesitas okay s o s there in front ll o
yo movie oil muy bien
i order at kita Arita or you cannot lose
almost anything oh come on say it don't
kneel Tom you know me say Lynette and
music metal Grande OS s tonight
Chiquita pequeno una vez el lice Kira
Kira is Kira
Samina derecha is Kara Kara
well pelo hotel oh well they are no no
[Music]
see see must I say you say scared us
Sita Sita si si se pone a aquí porque
Mira a ver con las dos ojos you know
your key as the esto hace la gare de
ello you it's a phony
a little PR botella Dan but no I see aha
Allah go Televi told me your movie a
Odyssey at the name of love spread
hey this is hipposaurus Iko tremulous
here is this thing hey Carla yo what's
up dude I love it out of the way okay in
English out of the world do small spaces
but it what is that noise is not loud at
all that I must a spicy or not me hey
mice it's crazy it like I can't it's not
a straight i'm you cometa please know it
is the way that pero Ellison si muy bien
con el español colossal and oh is that
got me really here Ami's instrucciones
Elsa you know
so you know who your therapy and more
from where we are at it destroy or who
your sanity is repetier estoy
estoy muy muy orgullosa Oh since when
does Capone ness15 ask upon this canal
releases or who you saw do I go up on
the way it's a video that's a survey
look at this toy this you know better -
can watch ah oui bien sur ce CE OS LOL @
y la casa I read on the Sun wasn't at
the process of vodka earlier saying it
was in well what
[Music]
estoy muy orgulloso dirty Mira quanto
termina Mo's mere acquainted urban ammos
yeah si muy bien Amer oh yeah maro SL
Ultimo at difficile witty si bueno Mira
esto vemos Hondo juntos para completar
esto pero todavía tenemos tres mess
cajas hace que vamos a tomar una vida la
palabra que vamos a ser no Mira Mira
Mira
no no Mira difficile no pero que vamos a
hacer ahora
yeah - yeah guitar dynamos esto que
vamos hacer tengo hambre
we've en vamos me Tula moving with speed
C
[Music]
BAM was a sin that you robo despues
Thomas ah there's me naturally look if
they say no I need to know cabeza
dan was I take it with me - you mean the
Ian
[Music]